hey yes what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so this is day number 11
in my quarantine hotel in hong kong
and i have to say guys that i'm pretty
excited because i'm having a lot of
calls
with some traders from very lynch
goldman sachs
i'm actually building a team of training
guys it's gonna be
like very interesting for you to see
it's gonna be on my discord
we're gonna have basically different uh
strategies so there's gonna be you know
the
usual technical analysis that i'm doing
and i have a friend that is asset
manager goodman says he's gonna
probably manage his own book so we're
gonna see who is winning he's gonna be
so full of information i can't wait to
start this
but today guys what you guys want to see
is
amc price action so let's get into it
[Music]
so as usual we start now in the 15
minutes time frame
and i'm gonna remind you what i was
saying yesterday we're gonna see
everything that happened during this
last week's day of trading session
we're gonna see what happened in this
last day of the week in the training
session
and we're gonna of course see again the
different scenarios that we're having
and try to analyze all the information
that we get from this market
so let's start here my last scenario
guys was that so we were here let me
zoom in a little bit
we were sitting around 37 38 here area
guys i was bullish i posted on my
discord that there was 70
chance that the market rebounds here and
look what
happened so i was a bit wrong here on
the very short term
but on the medium term i mean this is
totally fine to have
this is what i was explaining my
yesterday's video it's totally fine to
have
here some access uh to the 35 level that
we hit yesterday by the way my tread
that i posted there
as well was by 37 by 35 stop plus 24.5
so for now guys i'm in the money i have
an average
price of 36 and so just to tell you guys
that technical analysis of course will
not be
always right all right this is not the
point the point of doing technical
analysis is to be more right than
wrong and especially your profits must
have set
your losses of course so that you're
profitable so
here we are making money even if the
first scenario didn't happen so you know
this is the beauty of it
so here what i wanted to show you guys
yes so look
look what happened here at the open so i
told you guys i posted this as well on
my discord that
here this streamline is the trendline we
want to see broken
to know that we move higher so first
let's see what happened here oh
interesting
and they open bam we move higher on the
15 minutes time frame and we got
rejected we close below
so we don't have the breakout and we
don't have the confirmation so this is
definitely not a breakout it's not even
a fake out all right the fake out
for me occurs when you have all the
breakout characteristics so two candles
in the time frame you're watching above
your trend line with strong associated
volume this is
a breakout and then if it comes back
below the trend line
then it's a fake out so we can see that
here there is no
breakout you can also see that here we
have the breakout yes this is the
the main reason i'm bullish here on the
daily time frame
we have here a beautiful breakout we
have retested the 37 area this is why i
thought it would hold we have some
excess
here but it's fine i showed you guys
that this happened already a few months
ago
let me show you quickly again this is
exactly what happened here guys
this is exactly what happened when you
we had the breakout in may guys
and i told you guys i gave you of course
this trend on my channel back
at this time and we had the same
phenomenon just a little bit we had some
excesses
maybe you know to clean some buyers you
know this
could be you know some kind of strategy
that you know you just sell heavy
so that you know that a lot of buyers
gonna have stop-losses here and they're
out of the game so you
you know it's it's a way to avoid a
strong move
maybe so here for me it's not changing
that much you know i'm still of course
bullish on the short medium and long
term all right so i'm
very bullish here yeah here we didn't
have the breakout
then we moved lower we went to the 35
level as expected guys this was the next
support level i gave you as well this
support
the reason behind is that you have here
in the previous move up
this is the way you find your support
areas you check the lows
and when you had some consolidation some
reactions so here we have a low
with some consolidation here here and
especially here
so you know that 35 is a support level
you know that it's going to
hold the price if you want to make some
scalping even if i don't
advise you guys to do scalping on amc
because there is too much volatility you
can still buy 35 and start 37 you know
it's a winner
easy one but it's not the point of my
videos guys i don't i'm not here for you
to do some scalping i'm here
for you to find the good entry levels if
you want the nice
profit taking levels as well so here we
move lower
then we found support and just you know
i want to say guys even if here i was
wrong which i definitely was because i
told you that my preferred scenario was
we
rebound right away it's interesting to
notice that 37
was actually a support level so i was
wrong on the outcome of the scenario but
i was right to a point that 37 is a
strong support level
that now became resistance on the short
term all right
so just keep this in mind so it became
resistance we put it
in orange now this breakout didn't occur
so let me get rid of it and
here guys what do we have finally
the breakout so let's see if it's a real
breakout you guys know how to do it
because i showed you many times but
let's do it together
you check what is the volume on the
breakout candle
so here where is the breakout exactly so
the breakout candle on the 15th is this
one right
so it's the one at 2pm u.s time i think
so let's check the volume at 2pm and
let's see if they were bigger
than the one before okay so at 2pm
not such a big volume but the one right
after is
definitely bigger twice as much as the
one just
before and the one just after all right
so this gives you indication
this tells you that this breakout so
once again let's see if i did it
perfectly guys it's
important to do it perfectly
to really know which candle you're
watching okay
i'm just trying to connect here and here
yeah okay it's good so you can see that
here we have
it's not perfect the volume arrived just
after but guys you know
maybe this trendline would be slightly
different if i use five minutes time
frame
or 30 minutes time frame so for me it's
good it's a
valid breakout but it's confirmed so
this is for me a breakout
that is confirmed that is suggesting
that at least on the short term we're
gonna start moving higher
so i don't think 37 would hold i think
we're gonna break it
we're gonna go to the next resistance
level you know and so on and so forth
probably doing a one two three four five
so this is my preferred scenario guys
for today i hope this time
it's gonna be 100 right not only correct
on the
support and resistance level i also want
to be correct on the outcome guys so
let's
find out so let's see what happens here
here we have a question but at least
we'll move to the 50 area
by next week you know maybe wednesday
friday you know this is maybe not
perfectly accurate maybe we're going to
concentrate a bit more you know maybe
we're going to have something like this
i don't know okay so here guys we need
to analyze of course what is happening
here it's going to be very interesting
but once again i'm going to give you a
lot of clues of what this market wants
to do of what i think it would do once
again this is only my view guys
i will not be always right as you saw
this already but i'm really doing my
best to
guide you through what i'm seeing and i
think that the method i'm providing
is as long as you kind of follow the
basic rules which is by using stop
losses
it's almost never you're losing money
and sometimes you can
make very nice trades so this is the
purpose of what i'm trying to do
are we good here what else and one more
thing i wanted to discuss with you guys
i heard about the death
cross okay some of you guys posted that
on my comments so i tried to look for it
so the death cross is when you have the
200 period moving average that is
crossing the 50
or the 20 crossing the the 50 something
like this
try to look for it first i go on a daily
okay here i don't have any cross between
the 20 and the 50s so then i go on the
flowers
so you can see the moving averages there
here guys all right so in blue and
purple you can see that
the blue one which is faster the 20 is
not
crossing the 50 so i'm going on the four
hours and here i see it
okay i see crystal clear we have the 50
crossing the 200 so this is
a golden cross in this direction it's a
death cross
oh interesting let's see when is the
last time we had it
look at that how funny
it happened exactly at the same time
when we had the same breakout
with the same tricks given by the market
with the same
overselling pressure that is here that
led us
to the 78.6 retracement level of
fibonacci
how funny because this is exactly what
we're having here again
again the death crash the breakout that
is
re-tested okay we didn't go as low but
we broke the 61.8 percent at 37.
so guys maybe we're gonna keep grinding
a bit lower that's
that's possible as well before bouncing
back but i
expect here the market to strongly
bounce back let's see how this breakout
occurred
just quickly
breaking retested and we go higher
okay so this is probably what's going to
happen guys so we might retest it again
we might retest the 35
area again i don't think we would go
over and then
bam we move higher that's my view so
let's find out
let's see what happens here i hope you
guys enjoyed this video i hope i managed
to explain once again what i'm trying to
do what is technical analysis how i use
my tools
try to explain you know everything that
i know this is why i
have this channel i want to transmit i
want to pass the knowledge guys
so i hope i managed to do it here so if
you enjoyed this video please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button guys
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
so stay close to shore see you guys